why are we friends i'm a dick
sherlock holmes
are you just sitting there
inserting and uninserting your keycard
stop
dry humping the doorknob
sexual powers
okay hey everybody um
my cousin is here this time
his name's aj
what's up guys
oh man we already did that thing where
we like say hi to the audience and sound
like a generic internet game player
yeah
whatever oh we already screamed
leaderboards extra oh wait options i
mean
credits damn it this menu is giving me
such a hard time exit game exit game
leaderboard i keep
what
why is it like that i press down
and it goes
okay so basically this is a game where
you walk around in the woods and try not
to get diddled by an angry businessman
i've never played this game before so if
i poop my pants
it's all you guys fault um
i mean
try not to
i'll try
you'll you'll give it the old college
try
okay so we were actually playing for
like 13 minutes already and i forgot to
turn on the audio so just none of it
recorded and i sound like a huge jackass
okay
man how much is this place worth look at
the sign
um
oh i can zoom
uh
kate
see that must be the lady that wait that
girl
yeah wait wait wait hold on hold on
what do you think would happen if i
tried to call that number
i don't know what the [ __ ]
i just heard a whole bunch of footsteps
when i stood completely still
the hype is throat adjusting all right
let's let's book oh
uh a third-person perspective but i mean
you get places faster oh yeah
this place does not look that bad it's
kind of pretty yeah
looks really nice
i would probably stay there i would i
would buy a timeshare out here oh wait
timeshares are bad
it's like you all buy the same place but
then you have to like take turns using
it and if one of you does not feel like
cleaning up the next person comes in and
then there's just like beer bottles and
jizz stains everywhere
what does this place remind you of
i don't know
didn't you say it reminded you uh of uh
oh
oh i think it reminds me of uh
this show on cartoon network
um do you remember what it was called
with the animals in the woods camp
laszlo
yeah that was a good show i remember it
i remember not liking it because like
the majority episodes were about that
platypus who was a huge
and yeah and i haven't seen it in so
long oh
well i'm gonna replace that with
something funny and i hate how ninety
percent of spongebob episodes were about
squidward
cause squidward's a [ __ ]
ass [ __ ] head [ __ ]
can't wait for that this is gonna be
great
league of women voters
what's up everyone
this is
what
why
no please
that we're supposed to meet here are we
supposed to are we trying to buy this
house oh
no cigars we need to just
smoke a hundred thousand cigars
oh i'm gonna play moonlight sonata and
then in a secret passageway will open in
the mansion
i got that achievement already the grand
penis i mean pianist
those noises though
but there's a message
some guy speaking in a monotone voice
it's being like
hey
i'm gonna come over to your house and
help you move stuff
you know
it'll be really nice let me know when
you want me to come on over and i'll uh
help you move furniture and whatnot
hey baby are you my pinky toe cuz i want
to bang you on every piece of furniture
in my house
ow
anyway
god sorry
he thought it was pretty funny
this door needs a key
hey does anyone out there have a key i
could use
nah no one's responding
it is dark as balls and
we have to go find a flashlight
whoa did you see that flash what there
it is it was in a different spot than it
was last time they tried to trick me
cheeky bastards
hello oh nope
y'all probably have to do that thing
where like you're too hard to hear like
jackson was because he sat halfway
across the what
what
what the hell
tonight
closing that [ __ ]
you can't have my butt
too many rooms
is he out there
hello
i keep expecting to just look over and
there's this big white face pressed up
against one of the windows like like i
look over
and then he's just there and he's just
like boo i'm like ah you know
yeah bill's here
okay i knew where the keys were the
whole time but i'm worried to progress
okay i'm just going to look at the end
of the hall and he's just standing there
just
just jacking it
the fact that i don't see him out there
actually worries me
[ __ ]
what
what does that one say um
to the woods
it's almost like i should go somewhere
somewhere woods related
i just
what
where's the scream
here you have the headphones
i don't want to listen to this anymore
just hanging out is always the worst
part for me
i feel like oh my god what was that what
was that i heard someone throw a pipe at
a wall six corridors down from me in
dead space and now i'm just
my space suit is filled to burst
[ __ ] door oh
i mean let me know if you hear something
horrible in the distance
boy that frame rate
okay oh my gosh i'm like
we're gonna guest is
you're gonna get diddled by a
businessman oh let's go on the slide
i don't even care if there's a rapist
monster out there
we're going down this this [ __ ] slide
so
you